les phases de tests viennent de débuter
au l'Atmos ce nano satellite destiné à
partir dans l'espace dans quelques mois
et passer sur ce vibreur sous la
responsabilité des scientifiques de
cette observatoire yvinois objectif
simuler le départ d'une fusée pour ce
bijou de technologie baptisé inspire
cette
on le met à rue des preuves donc en
résumé on prend le satellite on le fixe
sur un pot un pot vibrant et on va
générer des excitations donc on va faire
des accélérations qui peuvent être
naturels mais aussi aléatoire donc on
essaye d'avoir un environnement qui se
rapproche le plus de ce que transmet une
fusée lors d'un lancement d'autres
essais sont effectués régulièrement par
la dizaine de chercheurs qui travaillent
sur ce projet ici dans cette
observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on simule la
sortie du satellite dans l'espace ou
encore la puissance du rayonnement
solaire sur cet instrument ça nous
permet de faire des tests sur les
cellules solaires elles-mêmes mais aussi
sur les détecteurs
donc les détecteurs sont testés et
étalonnés pour pouvoir faire les mesures
les plus précises en orbite en orbite ce
petit satellite de 3 kg rejoindra son
grand frère uvsq7 lancée en janvier 2021
un début de constellation de satellite
nouvelle génération qui aura pour
objectif de fournir des données
scientifiques exploitables ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que grâce aux satellites
on arrive à observer des variables ce
qu'on appelle des variables climatiques
essentielles qui ne sont observables que
depuis l'espace c'est pour ça qu'on a un
intérêt à utiliser ces satellites pour
pouvoir observer notre Terre notre
planète et pouvoir suivre des paramètres
clés des paramètres essentiels vis-à-vis
de l'État l'état de la planète si les
tests sont concluants le satellite
devrait partir en janvier 2023 avec la
société SpaceX le lancement se fera
depuis la base de lancement de Cap
Canaveral en Floride aux États-Unis